I think to some degree it's true that
all culture is somewhat unfriendly to
the individual I you know when they when
their heavy arm falls on your shoulder
and they tell you that you're going to
be sent off to some foreign hellhole to
kill people as a young man you
definitely suddenly get the notion that
culture is not your friend
but perhaps you know if you're a 12 year
old boy in an Amazonian tribe and they
announced that now it's time for the
two-week abandonment in the woods from
which if you live to tell the tale
you'll become a full member of society
I'm not sure those kids greet that with
the leap of joy in their heart it's like
oh my god now this we knew it was coming
I went through rites of passage like
that that we're excruciating where I
grew up in western Colorado you weren't
a real man unless sometime between 12
and 16
you killed an elk a hunting season every
October was an excuse for this insane
rite of passage and my father was
unquestioning inhabitant of his culture
and so this was always in front of me
and when I was I guess when I was 12 I
went the first time I didn't get
anything the second year we went out and
and you know my father I sure had no
idea what a what a wilted pansy I was
in this situation because I have hid it
from a mom and I I was concerned about
all kinds of things and and eventually
this situation arose where they put me
up on this point and gave me a gun and
said if anything came by to blow it away
and you know by god this thing you know
chose to sacrifice itself as far as I
could tell I mean it did not behave at
all like ealth behaved it basically just
came out of the woods Stood Still light
pulled down on it close my eyes pray
there was an enormous noise when my open
my eyes there was nothing whatsoever to
be seen I felt an enormous relief that
this thing had escaped and walked over
to find it dead as if Dorothy and
the oak leaves dipped in the blood the
cup of blood the whole thing I mean I
couldn't believe how I have istic this
stuff was however I never had to he's my
father again
I was home free that everything was
forgiven from that moment on but it
brought home to me how uncomfortable
culture is and to and always has been I
think